Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Riccardo Sasso
Il giorno in cui sono stato chiamato
a diventare direttore di una redazione,
ho provato dentro di me
emozioni contrastanti:
paura, ansia;
ma anche stupore, gioia e entusiasmo.
Quello che si è venuto
a creare, dentro di me,
è una sorta di disordine emotivo
dettato dal fatto che non sapevo
quale percorso complesso
andavo ad affrontare;
ma soprattutto,
che avrei dovuto abbandonare
la mia "comfort zone".
Scrivere un articolo, infatti,
è molto diverso
rispetto a scrivere e creare
un piano editoriale
che altri giornalisti devono seguire.
Quella, per me, è stata l'opportunità
per migliorarmi a livello
personale e professionale;
e migliorare LifeGate,
il network di informazioni
che dirigo da cinque anni
e che da oltre 20 fa divulgazione
sui temi dello sviluppo sostenibile.
Quella, infatti, è stata un'opportunità
che ha sì creato disordine nella mia vita,
ma è stato un disordine positivo.
Quanti di voi possono dire
di aver ricevuto una chiamata analoga
che vi ha fatto uscire
dalla vostra area di confort
ma vi ha dato anche l'opportunità
di migliorarvi come individui?
Ebbene, proviamo a traslare
tutto ciò a livello globale.
Proviamo a immaginare che quella chiamata
l'ha fatta la comunità scientifica
chiedendo a noi, come umanità,
di accettare la sfida della sostenibilità
per uscire dalla crisi climatica
che stiamo vivendo.
Una sfida enorme,
che a molti può apparire
come una montagna insormontabile;
ma che in realtà ci dà la possibilità
di crescere come specie,
di usare la nostra intelligenza
per vivere in armonia con la natura,
e in equilibrio con le altre specie
animali e vegetali.
Quella chiamata della scienza
è arrivata per davvero, qualche mese fa,
con l'ultimo rapporto
definitivo dell'IPCC,
il gruppo intergovernativo
delle Nazioni Unite
che riunisce tutti i maggiori esperti
di cambiamenti climatici.
Sarà l'ultima chiamata, questa:
perché non ce ne saranno altre,
da qui alla fine del decennio.
Una chiamata che ci ha detto
esattamente cosa dobbiamo fare
per allontanarci dal baratro climatico
al quale ci siamo
pericolosamente avvicinati,
e fermare il riscaldamento globale
prima che sia troppo tardi.
E per farlo, la soluzione è molto facile:
dobbiamo smettere di bruciare
combustibili fossili
come carbone, petrolio e gas.
Una soluzione facile,
che ci fa stare meglio tutti,
nessuno escluso;
ma a che molti di noi può creare
anche un senso di frustrazione,
di ansia - anzi: di eco-ansia -
per vedere tutto intorno a noi
la perdita di biodiversità.
Una sorta di disordine,
che in questo caso
possiamo definire distruttivo.
Ma che cosa provoca questo disordine,
tutto intorno a noi?
Beh, il fatto che consumiamo le risorse
che la terra ci mette a disposizione
a un ritmo insostenibile.
Andiamo a debito di risorse con la terra.
E per definire tutto ciò
c'è anche un'espressione,
che è: Overshoot Day.
E sta ad indicare, esattamente,
la data in cui andiamo
a debito di risorse con la terra.
Pensate che per soddisfare
la fame di risorse naturali
di tutta la popolazione globale
servirebbero 1,7 pianeti.
Ma la terra è una sola.
L'anno scorso questa data,
l'Overshoot Day,
si è verificata il 28 luglio,
ben cinque mesi prima
della fine naturale dell'anno.
Vi chiederete, dunque,
come è possibile tutto ciò,
com'è possibile andare a debito
se la Terra è una.
Beh, perché noi, Paesi del nord del mondo,
abbiamo uno standard di vita
che non possiamo permetterci.
Andiamo a debito di risorse
sottraendole ai paesi del Sud del mondo.
Facciamo l'esempio della Repubblica
Democratica del Congo:
è un paese enorme dell'Africa centrale,
è ricchissimo di risorse,
ma non ha un Overshoot Day.
Vuol dire che non va a debito di risorse:
e quelle che le rimangono a credito
vengono esportate e sfruttate
dalle multinazionali
per andare in Paesi stranieri,
dove vengono processate e lavorate
per andare ad alimentare
la loro, di ricchezza,
non certo quella dei congolesi.
Pensate che in Italia abbiamo raggiunto
l'Overshoot Day il 15 maggio.
E per soddisfare la fame
di risorse che abbiamo,
per soddisfare la fame di risorse
di quasi 60 milioni di Italiani,
non serve un'Italia, nemmeno due:
ma servono cinque Italie.
E quindi, fondamentalmente,
adesso noi che cosa dobbiamo fare?
Dobbiamo chiederci come possiamo
soddisfare queste risorse
in modo gestibile.
Pensiamo ad esempio all'energia.
Quanti di voi hanno sentito dire
che non basteranno mai,
soprattutto le fonti rinnovabili,
che ci lasceranno al buio?
Ma in realtà, non è così:
se noi andiamo a pensare al fatto
che le energie rinnovabili
sono sostenibili,
e se andiamo a immaginare
che ci sono paesi che hanno già raggiunto
il loro fabbisogno elettrico
al 100% da fonti rinnovabili,
beh, allora le cose cambiano.
Dalla Danimarca al Marocco,
dalla Svezia all'Uruguay
hanno raggiunto il loro equilibrio
non soltanto con il sole e con il vento -
che molti reputano poco affidabili,
perché sono fonti intermittenti -
ma l'hanno raggiunta, anche,
attraverso altre fonti rinnovabili,
come l'idroelettrico
o il moto delle maree.
E allora, non è vero
che le fonti rinnovabili
sono insostenibili:
sono tutti falsi miti,
e questi sono dei luoghi comuni.
Pensate che ancora oggi
ci sono milioni di persone
che non hanno accesso all'energia.
E le fonti rinnovabili potrebbero portarle
proprio laddove la rete non arriva.
E poi, c'è tutta la questione
dell'alimentazione,
della produzione del cibo.
Noi qui siamo abituati ad avere cibi
di tutte le stagioni, sempre, ovunque:
siamo abituati ad avere
le fragole in inverno,
per festeggiare San Valentino;
ma siamo abituati anche
a mangiare carne tutti i giorni,
solo perché possiamo
acquistarla a basso costo.
Ma, secondo voi, è normale pagare
due euro un hamburger
se vi dicessi che per fare
un chilo di manzo
ci vogliono mille litri d'acqua?
Mille litri per un chilo!
Soprattutto, adesso che abbiamo capito
quanto è preziosa l'acqua,
e quanto è importante gestirla
nel modo corretto.
Guardate le alluvioni in Emilia-Romagna.
Ebbene: no, tutto questo non è normale.
Infatti, secondo uno studio tedesco
pubblicato sulla rivista
scientifica "Nature",
se andassimo a calcolare
i costi ambientali e sociali
del produrre carne
da allevamenti intensivi,
e che quindi creano
inquinamento e deforestazione,
beh dovremmo pagare quella carne
addirittura il 150% in più.
E poi ci sono le verdure di stagione,
che si chiamano così
perché dovremmo trovarle
solo in un certo periodo dell'anno:
e invece no, noi sugli scaffali
dei supermercati
troviamo zucchine, melanzane
e pomodori tutto l'anno.
E, secondo voi, vuol dire
rinunciare a qualcosa
se andassimo a sottrarre dello spazio
proprio a questa varietà di verdure?
Oppure, invece, ci si aprirebbe davanti
la scoperta di altre varietà di verdure
che veramente sono di stagione,
ma che non vengono coltivate
in maniera intensiva?
Quanti di voi possono dire
di essere andati al supermercato
per comprare la borragine,
o la barba di frate?
E se vi dicessi
che anche l'ortica si può mangiare?
Ebbene, tutto ciò ci consente di avere
una dieta più varia,
che sicuramente fa stare meglio
noi come persone
ma far stare meglio anche la terra,
perché un terreno coltivato
in modo più vario
è un terreno più sano,
più vivo, più fertile.
Mentre le monoculture hanno bisogno
di tanta energia, di pesticidi
per mantenere alta la produttività;
e quindi sono legate a doppio filo,
di nuovo, con i combustibili fossili.
Eppure, un quarto degli italiani
si è detto già pronto
a mangiare meno carne,
ma soprattutto ad avere
una dieta più varia,
se solo conoscesse, scoprisse
quelle varietà nuove.
E questo, di nuovo,
secondo i dati dell'Osservatorio Nazionale
sullo stile di vita sostenibile
che LifeGate tiene ogni anno dal 2015.
Quindi siamo pronti,
tutti noi siamo pronti:
in questa sala sono sicuro
che accettereste di buon grado
scelte che andassero
proprio in questa direzione,
in direzione dello sviluppo sostenibile.
Però ancora oggi, troppo spesso
il dibattito è inquinato
da messaggi allarmistici
delle multinazionali,
che ci dicono
che è proprio cambiando
il sistema di produzione attuale
andremmo incontro a una catastrofe.
Ma la catastrofe la stiamo già vivendo
sia ambientale che climatica,
l'abbiamo visto tutti.
Per fortuna, però,
ci sono anche delle buone azioni
per migliorare la vita di tutti.
Ad esempio, nel 2015 sono stati adottati
gli Obiettivi di Sviluppo Sostenibile,
che in acronimo inglese
si dicono anche SDGs:
probabilmente li avete sentiti anche così.
Sono 17 obiettivi,
che vanno dalla lotta alla povertà
alla fame nel mondo.
Ma non si può pensare di sconfigge
la fame nel mondo
alimentando il sistema
di produzione attuale,
che deforesta
e trasforma in discariche gli oceani.
Al contrario,
negli SDGs ci sono anche obiettivi
quali la tutela della biodiversità,
sia terrestre che sottomarina.
E noi dobbiamo raggiungere
lo scopo di sconfiggere la fame,
quindi di dare da mangiare
a otto miliardi di persone,
ricordandoci dei limiti planetari,
e quindi tutelando la biodiversità.
Solo così potremo raggiungere
un vero equilibrio sostenibile.
Perché siamo tutti interconnessi
su questo pianeta,
dipendiamo tutti l'uno dall'altro.
E anche la Terra è essa stessa
un organismo vivente:
e se a star male
è una specie animale o vegetale,
allora ne risentiamo tutti.
L'abbiamo visto, in due anni di pandemia.
E allora dobbiamo avere
l'umiltà di imparare
da chi è su questo pianeta
da molto più tempo di noi:
perché siamo solo dei bambini,
se rapportati all'età della Terra,
e come dei bambini dobbiamo avere
l'umiltà di imparare:
ad esempio dalle piante,
che sono su questo pianeta
da milioni di anni
e hanno raggiunto il loro, di  equilibrio.
E invece no,
spesso ci comportiamo come quello studente
che in classe si nasconde
dietro la sedia di un compagno
quando l'insegnante ha deciso
che quella è l'ora dell'interrogazione.
Come se evitare quell'interrogazione
fosse qualcosa di positivo:
e invece no, non fa altro
che prolungare il malessere e l'ansia,
perché tanto poi quel momento
sarebbe comunque arrivato
che lo volessimo oppure no.
E allora, perché invece non cercare
di approcciare la sfida
della sostenibilità
a viso aperto,
tentando di pensare, anche,
al sollievo che proveremo
quando avremo superato
quell'esame a pieni voti?
Perché solo così
potremo porre fine al disordine
che abbiamo causato
nella nostra casa comune,
e raggiungere un nuovo equilibrio.
Perché alla fine, tutti abbiamo un solo
e semplice obiettivo davanti a noi:
quello di vivere meglio, di vivere tutti:
ma soprattutto, il più a lungo possibile.
(Applausi)